and i got to say too man that uh you
know for
for for all the stuff that that i've
seen
like uh i it's really refreshing how how
candid you are thank you and uh you know
i like i i think you're in a good spot
dude thank you yeah good place i
appreciate that because like
the thing with the internet and the
pandemic definitely like
fast forwarded the internet so much
because people had nothing to do it like
evolved it way quicker you know
uh there's such a false narrative of me
on the internet that i'm like a bar
[ __ ] [ __ ] like illiterate like a dick
[ __ ] like mean person but like i
always tell people
and i know it's not possible to meet
everybody in the world and have five
minutes to talk to him but if you would
just sit down and talk to me for five
minutes you would you would probably
like me because i'm genuinely a nice guy
and polite you know i don't want to
start any issues i just want to help
people and if you still hate me then not
your decision i can't change that but
you know just don't believe everything
you see on the internet because it's not
a lot of real real
i i agree with that and and i i don't
know that i've seen anything suggesting
that you're not a nice guy i haven't
heard anything saying well there was the
tupac
uh incident something that you said
tupac
yeah but that was back when i was barred
out and they would wake me up at 5 00 am
and i was cranky uh to go to the iheart
radios you know and i rated and and i
don't feel this way anymore tupac is a
legend but i i wanted to get the
interview over with the interviewer was
annoying and she just kept speeding this
and she's like what do you feel about
tupac and i was like two out of ten and
that was like such a big catalyst of
hate you know what i mean yeah but at
the same time so i don't have to like
i was
i was barred out i was cr like cranky
you know everybody just got your dick
sucked by six chicks six [ __ ]
[ __ ] 10 chicks yeah you're just
thinking about knows what i got
who knows what i got my dick
uh no but you know like um
yeah but no tupac is definitely a legend
and i i i would like to stop receiving
uh death threats for that
america if you thought jackass forever
was crazy oh boy do i have a show for
you it's a multimedia comedy show called
the bucket list tour and the stuff i
filmed for this show is way too hot for
jackass like the general anesthesia bike
ride the vasectomy olympics and sky
jacking the footage is so intense we
have full grown men passing out at
almost every city this bus goes to
so if you think you can handle it get
your tickets right now at stevo.com
[Applause]